quels sont vos loisirs et à quoi les
occupez-vous le samedi après-midi avec
des camarades dans les cafés on joue au
baby-foot
dans les cafés tout ça dans les balles
le soir vous avez un violon dingue le
modèle réduit d'avion je m'appelle
Jean-Jacques j'ai 18 ans mes parents
sont bourgeois j'aime beaucoup le cinéma
je fais une collection de porte-clés un
peu tout quoi je suis un peu de guitare
alors j'aime beaucoup la chasse et la
pêche je dis quoi quand je sais pas quoi
faire je suis avec des copains cinéma le
dimanche aussi quand je fais du sport
dans mon lycée là alors mon violon
dingue c'est de sport alors la plupart
du temps on est là à se balader dans les
rues à strumballer comme vous voulez de
la photo de trois fois par semaine
il en a dessiné club on a tout on a club
de théâtre